what's going on guys as many of you know
the first year of ua recently finished
in the my
academia manga and i think it's fair to
say it was a very very long time coming
after a year of exams joint training
battles and villain attacks it's now
time for us to predict what's going to
happen in the second year
and with me today is shonen and vocal
pineapple how are you guys doing
i'm doing great and i'm excited to be on
a video
in front of turtle kirk's audience yes
well yeah this is the first time you've
been here i think we've done like what
five collabs at this point something
like that
yeah but i'm sure you've had a hundredth
out yeah you've probably had a hundred
thousand subs since my last collab with
you
so hello all of the new normies and also
we have pineapple this is the first time
on the channel as well for you
yes of course thank you for having me
here no worries man i've had comments
like asking me when you're going to come
on the channel for like
probably a year i hear a lot about like
people commenting about like me just
being missing i feel like
i definitely go missing in action a lot
so that's kind of par for the course
just for the viewers um today basically
all of us have written five predictions
for the second uwa
and i guess over the course of the
conversation we'll be seeing how much we
overlap in what we're predicting but
yeah spoiler winning ahead for any anime
only so
if you do not read the micro academia
manga then we will be talking about
big spoilers here but do check out their
channels um before you go
so tell me the first prediction jonathan
i think you wanted to go first
yes shinso will replace izuku
oh yeah yeah okay yeah is it was i right
in assuming that we had all wrote this
down
i don't have that one written down but
i'm definitely with that one yeah i
didn't have it written down either but
to be honest i i thought he would join
class 1a regardless of whether rizuka
was there but yeah i mean the fact
the fact that zuku's left yeah he slots
him perfectly
i was waiting for an excuse for this to
happen and
i don't know it just seemed like it was
going to be something that was more
significant than
what it could be possibly because you
know that was like or it is going to be
a huge element of season five and then
it's
kind of just abandoned and never even
remotely mentioned again i don't even
think shinso shows up again after
chapter yeah it doesn't what 213
yeah it is quite interesting i actually
did a small prediction about shinzo but
yeah should i go into that yeah um so
basically like one of my predictions was
that uh
all for one or shiguraki would attack ua
and uh
the way that ties into shinzo is because
i was thinking that
if an attack like that happened shinzo
might use his brainwashing quirk on
shigaraki or or for one whoever it might
be
um because we we all know shinzo's
secondary purpose in this series is to
send people to the vestige world
so i imagine that you know he would do
that and potentially that could be an
out for sugar rocky to finally be free
of one taking over his body
potentially obviously that's a very
specific theory but i think it would be
really interesting
yeah i i think i think it's plausible
because you know he's done it to deku
twice now
you know sugar rocky deserves a tone as
well i think so um yeah
i saw on twitter from people that went
to hori's art exhibit today that
uh one of the arts uh has shin so in his
hero costume in it so i'm sure we're
gonna end up seeing him
at some point in the future soon as you
know especially before because she
designed it
i'm assuming you're going to see it wait
that's huge he's here
so it's him and his hero costume along
with the rest of class 1a and everyone's
in their hero costumes
and apparently it's the big you know
final art for the exhibit but there's no
photos of it because you know you can't
take photos of it
um but i saw it described by audrey on
twitter
and she said he has like fishnets and
purple and white there's a really good
description on her twitter uh
just that i can't remember right off the
top of my head but yeah
so i wonder if that kind of confirms
he's with one a
if he's in that group shot so no one b
just one a
no i don't think there's anyone b
students in it i think it's all the
class 1a students deku
and shinto in his hero costume okay
listen i mean that's
i i need to see that like i don't even
miss that i also
miss that all of the art from that
exhibit i need it i need to have it in
some sort of like book form i need to
see it
i need that uh all my statue in my room
right now
yeah the gold statue i need someone to
put the sign on it
but i'm moving on to the next prediction
pineapple do you want to go next all
right so my first one i have written
down
is the ua trader will be revealed while
everyone and their parents are at ua
and deku isn't there i feel like this is
like
probably something that could really
raise a lot of tension it's a good way
to get back into that plot line because
a lot of people like to think that that
plot line has been dropped or that hurry
has forgotten about it or something
which i think is really funny
um but i feel like right now with
everyone back at ua it's the perfect
time to maybe get back into that plot
line if you know
we're ever gonna get back there
especially with us heading towards
the end or getting into the final
chapter i think
this would be the perfect time and do
you think like the trader would
intentionally like reveal themselves or
do you think it's more like they're
being found out by someone
well my like strange thing is
like you're saying that you think that
maybe all for one and shiguraki might
attack a
ua what if the traitor lets them in what
if he
there are some sort of defenses that
they slip past because someone allows
them to get through
it's like a more important thing than
just something that happens like
off-screen right so i would hope that
it's something that's
you know really really tension-building
and something that would require deku's
attention
and and everyone else's attention
because you know it's been a long time
since we've been trying to figure out
who the
trader is right like we've we've heard
that it's not any of the students
that's kind of not really been a
question for a long time and that makes
me wonder like who is it
who who could it be i feel like it has
to be somebody kind of important
unless it's going to be someone who it's
like oh you know
like yeah i really hope it's not like
someone irrelevant
because after all the and it's been so
long you know after solo we can't just
have it be
some irrelevant something random yeah
that would be that that'd be terrible
that'd be terrible
we need to be someone that we actually
care about someone that we just wouldn't
believe or you know something like that
do you have any picks for who it might
be right now either of you yes
so i wrote this down as well the i wrote
down the trader reveal
i mean it essentially has to happen if
we are truly in the final acted series
there's no better time to do it
obviously than now but
going back to nezu and how horukoshi may
have forgotten about this the
traitor storyline obviously he hasn't
forgotten because he did mention it back
in
uh chatter 240 something right that was
the last time was brought out when nezu
was talking to
the other uh teachers he was like well
there's been no incidents in the last
four months so i guess that means
nobody's a traitor or there's no student
is a traitor or something right
something like that
i think he was yeah what he was saying
was that like after the next battle
we'll know if one of the students is a
traitor or not i think he was kind of
implying that if nothing happens during
you know the war that happened uh then
none of the students are traders and
obviously nothing did happen so i guess
we can assume that it's none of them
um so it must be a teacher i guess so
either that was
literally the wrap up to that storyline
which would be incredibly anti-climactic
yeah
unlike horikoshi's writing at least in
my opinion
or it's just i don't know he's been
letting it build up
subtly i mean obviously we all were
paying attention
very close to the war for multiple
reasons and one of them was to see if
there was going to be some kind of
traitor
you know slip up or something and as far
as i know there wasn't
so i would like to think that it's still
a student
rather than a teacher and uh
i'm guessing it's got to be hagakure at
this point yeah it'd be easy for her to
be the one
my theory was that she's like not even
like a teenager
she's like a full blown adult she's just
some adult yeah that's horrifying
i don't actually like the idea i've
never thought about that but we can't
know
um that is a really good idea actually
it's so ridiculous
i love it but other than that i have no
idea
other than that just out of left field
pitch my only random hail mary might be
that
aoyama might have some sort of
involvement or knowledge of who the
traitor is because there's that weird
conversation that he had with deku
about not trusting still waters that run
deep or something like that
i feel like aliyama has some sort of
like darkness
behind you know the obvious twinkling
and lights and all the glitz and glamour
um you know besides his backstory with
his quirk and whatnot
i feel like there's something more
taoyama and maybe not necessarily that
he's the traitor
but maybe he's like trying to figure it
out or maybe he has some sort of idea
and i really hope that he gets tied into
that somehow
so aoyama definitely suspicious and i
was always on the fence about
is that just a red herring from
horukoshi does he just want us to think
that
alyama is suspicious or that he's just
eccentric and like pseudo-french or
something but
there is that one really weird sequence
which i still can't make sense of it's
back in the training camp arc
when out i think it's a train camp arc
when aoyama's hiding behind the bushes
from dobby
and twice and dobby straight up sees him
and he doesn't do anything
i feel like dabi looked in that
direction but i'm not 100 sure he
actually saw ayama
like he was definitely going there and
ayama was like hiding behind the bush
but did he actually like physically see
who it was i don't
i'm not 100 on that i'll say that the
anime
makes it out that he sees him but maybe
the manga panel is a little more
ambiguous
yeah i'd have to check that yeah okay
well let's go over to
my prediction and i think this is
probably my most controversial one so
i'm gonna get it out
yeah pretty early uh and that is that
deku might not actually return to ua
once this is all over
um and now i had a couple reasons for
thinking this but i guess the primary
one at the front of my head was that
with the danger sense quirk you know
deku's gonna be sensing things happening
all the time and there's no way you can
make him sit in a classroom
he has a professional hero license no
one's going to stop him so i feel like
the pieces are in place for him to just
continue from this point onwards
be a bona fide hero and gradually get
his full hero license
just by you know doing practical work
rather than going back to school
um and also one other thing i would say
he is stronger probably than most pro
heroes in japan
i mean besides the top guys who could
touch deku i feel like he is
with all these powers he is just so op
there's barely anyone who could touch
him so
yeah i doubt he's going back to ua
though for the story purpose maybe he
will but i feel like realistically he
shouldn't
i really feel like there's not much
reason to go back to school for deku
besides
you know your friends and and
you know finishing the school and that
all my went to and all those like
symbolic things
i i don't really see him sitting in one
place too long especially while
shigaraki is
a threat i don't see it and even after
that just
you know what i mean deku with his will
to save people i agree there's no way
he's going to sit in a classroom when
someone needs help and the teacher is
going to tell him no
no exactly exactly and i feel like
there's you know
we all saw it the other the other week
when he took out muscular with one punch
basically
there's very few heroes who can do that
i mean yeah and there's probably the
only other one i can think of who could
come close
he's needed out there exactly without
him
a lot of people will be screwed so i
feel like yeah you're right he is 100
needed can't go back to school just
can't happen i never really like
i guess said it out loud that he wasn't
going to return but i've always kind of
just internally
felt that this was like the end of his
uh
tenure in ua for sure like once he's
left there was
no reason for him to go back not
necessarily because of his obligations
or anything
just it just felt like that narrative
wise whether he ultimately dies in the
end or just whatever else happens i just
don't
see him like going back to school
there's just no point it's like kobe
leaving uh high school to go to the nba
like
you're already good at that point yeah
yeah why would you go back to high
school
no point um shauna do you want to go
next
okay uh so this this was uh this is more
of a downer
uh an unfortunate realization but i
think it's going to be revealed
soon that there is no new students
coming to ua
meaning that there's no new freshman
class there's no new 1a there's no new
one b
and there is no sports festival
interesting
interesting well you know what the
sports festival thing is something that
i was thinking as well but
i didn't i didn't go that far i i didn't
imagine that there'd be no new students
but that is an interesting thought
there would be a lot of characters you
have to add into the seriousness late
that too it's like considering that the
series is coming to an end it makes it
extremely unlikely that it's going to
happen
and just also you know what's going on
in the or at least japan right now and i
guess the world as
uh by proxy too uh it's just unfortunate
as that i'll say is that that kind of
needs to be put out there because
realistically if this was continuing to
go on to a length that like bleach
naruto dary even say one piece would
then yeah for sure
introduce another 20 or 40 new
characters
into the story i mean don't even give
them all spotlight but at least just
give them a name and a panel or
something yeah and then you know maybe a
few of them are like hey i'm the new
bakugo type guy or something
but yeah the sports festival is even
more unfortunate in my opinion because
at least you could
have an excuse for having no new
students but then it's like maybe we'll
have a new sports festival but given the
way that the things are turning out they
just don't yeah that's the biggest
heartbreak
yeah because that that would have been
like an uh such a
such a fantastic portion of a latter
part of the series
there's so many things that needed to be
paid off in like a second sports
festival then now it's like oh
yeah i feel like i mean the whole
purpose of it in the first place was to
you know for kids to show off to the pro
heroes and maybe internships and stuff
like that
and the way heroes society is right now
you know heroes are
retiring they're resigning they're going
to other countries like
it's it's not really the right
environment for you to be doing a sports
festival yeah
they're reading the room probably yeah
yeah but
when it comes to the new year though i
feel like they could still have new
students because
i mean when we look at the series so far
how much have we seen of class 2a or
class 3a like
i mean we only know like the big three
and that one girl who
but besides that we don't actually need
to see them we just need to know they're
there
so i feel like you could just have a
one-off sentence where it's like oh the
the new ua students they've arrived
or something like that they don't need
to be important they could just be there
i mean i'll take that rather than
nothing i wonder how the teachers work
like do they continue with their class
into the next year or do they stay in
like what iso is still be their teacher
in two-way like oh
i assume he wouldn't be their homeroom
teacher i mean you know what that's
something i hadn't thought about oh
that's an odd question
potentially that maybe there are
teachers at ua that we don't actually
know yet
that would i would like that a lot i
feel like just some super badass
teachers
yeah i mean i would imagine they'd have
to be right because like there's so many
classes you know
class 3b like who's their teacher
probably not anyone we know i reckon
yeah who's teaching general studies yeah
oh is it no i'm just joking
out of nowhere yeah that's impressive
he's read the encyclopedia no no no no
that's just where it would be funny but
yeah like um it would be cool to see
like new teachers teaching the
new students and stuff like that um but
moving on to the next one so i had
a little bit of a weird prediction and
that was that we will get
a second my then academia arc and i know
that
might be weird for some people in the
comments i imagine many people don't
think that will happen
but i do have a reason and it was
basically this one panel we got um
after af escape from prism and uh
obviously it was you know all for one
controlling shigeru's body
and spinner says to him you know you're
not the guy i chose to follow and i feel
like many of the other people in the
league
might feel that same way redestro in
particular there might be a little bit
of a villain civil war potentially
where there's the side for sugaraki who
want him back and there's the other side
who just don't give a crap like dabby or
whoever else it may be who wants to
follow all for one or not
um so i feel like there's a lot to be
sorted out before the villains
eventually go and fight deku
you know it doesn't have to be a long
arc like the uh the previous model in
academia it could be
10 chapters maybe 15 chapters um but i
feel like we should get a villain
centered arc during the second year at
some point
i completely agree uh i my villain
academy is probably my second favorite
arc now in the series after the war arc
uh and even during the war arc i felt
like there were moments where the
villains kind of seemed like
they didn't really care about shigeraki
like there was that one electricity guy
who's like this is what we get for
waiting
uh and everyone in the basement ran to
read destro specifically for help
uh when everything and the mansion
started to go wrong and it just kind of
felt to me like
you know they're it's it's not really a
power struggle because rudestro doesn't
care
to take the power from shigaraki because
he's kind of accepted it but
there is still that issue of people
aren't really looking to shigaraki as
the leader right like they're looking
kind of
at redestro still if they're part of the
meta liberation army or this and that
and now you have that whole situation
with wall for one and i feel like it
just
kind of throws the whole leadership into
question so i do agree that there's
probably gonna have to be some sort of
structuring or something and now you
have all these villains just randomly
running around in the street like how do
you get everyone
together for any sort of final
confrontation
it did seem like there was like a line
being drawn
at the end of chapter 298 i think it was
when all for one drops off shigaraki and
like the the core of the league of
villains and then he just dips out
somewhere
and you know they ultimately were all i
mean the league of villains was
ultimately all he was saying
it's for shigaraki like they're down for
shigaraki not
down for all for one this is a tricky
situation because like
we already know that the league are
aware of all for one like they know he
is technically above shigaraki chicago's
master
but would they follow him probably not i
reckon
yeah i wouldn't think so all right so my
second prediction
is stain and gentle will both have some
sort of interaction of deku
at some point in the future um we've
seen that he's kind of
seeing a bunch of his old villains he uh
had that flashback a couple chapters ago
seeing everyone
and i think it'd be really fitting for
him to have a conversation with the two
of them
and for either of them to maybe help him
out so you know obviously gentle we've
seen him kind of on the track to going
back to
you know being a member of society i
think maybe it'd be cool if he
was some sort of vigilante hero or
something that'd be a really nice role
for him to step into especially
considering
you know that's kind of what he wanted
to do his entire life and
deku right now is having these
conversations with everyone
um asking them why they do things asking
them why they're villains
and i think it'd be really cool for him
to see a villain that he's already
fought against
in the role of kind of a hero and that
being because
of his words you know like that being
because he listened to
gentle's pain and what gentle was going
through and actually affected change and
dental that caused him to go from being
a villain
into being like i mean you know a
vigilante or a good guy or something
and i'm just wondering how that would
affect deku right now especially since
he's questioning everybody
i would love to see that i would love to
see gentlers like uh he'd probably be
like a
have a provisional license or something
like that right because if i'm
remembering correctly in the vigilantes
mango there was
an alternate way for people to get their
hero licenses like yeah you don't have
to go through yes
that's true and gentle did get a little
extra focus in those panels
uh in the flashback like everyone got
like kind of grouped together
out of the big villains and gentle and
uh la brava got like a
little bit of a bigger panel so i'm
wondering if gentle is going to come
back i would assume he is because
there's
that probably has to have some sort of
payoff i would imagine so i do hope we
see him again and we i know we're seeing
stain again
slowly we've seen him go and get his
sword again i
i'm wondering if he's going uh to find
yoroy musha
just ask him what his quirk is yeah we
need to know like we
saw this guy and we just have no idea
where his quirk is still it's
unbelievable
number nine he has armor and swords
that's all we get
so i would love to see that maybe have
like a little fight or something but i
guess that kind of goes against me
wanting staying to
meet up with deku and be like yeah hey
this is me this is why i do these things
how are you doing
do you need any help yeah by the way i
just killed the old number nine hero
yeah don't mind me yeah i completely
agree that gentle will come back for
sure i think it's guaranteed at this
point
uh and we don't even have to go down the
route of him getting a provisional
license or going through
a another alternative method i'm
assuming that like by the end of the
series it's gonna be just
pandemonium just even bigger than the
war arc uh essentially
and given that we're down a whole bunch
of heroes they're gonna be like you know
what um
if you can help just go out there you
know just go help go ahead
uh but as for my next thing i also
wrote down that he izuku would meet up
with
stain again because i do think that's
going to happen
but i'll go into my other one which i
think
might compound with that and it's that
all might is for sure going to die very
soon
uh i mean all my he's all might is going
with them
why you know like at the end of the last
chapter albeit was like hey
i'll tag a log with you guys i'm going
can i come and then even best jesus is
like
um are you sure that you should be
coming
he is a skinny old man like he has no
quirk
yeah i just don't get it like he must
know that he's setting himself up here
like in the back of his mind he must
think oh yeah there's a prediction i'm
gonna die around this time
i'm putting myself in harm's way i'm
actively going to find
the two strongest characters in the
series know the villains like
he maybe he wants to die i don't know
all while in gucci shades by the way and
just like the best time of his life wait
is that what his fancy car is
i'm not sure if it's exactly that but
it's just he's definitely bruce wayne
right now in a way that i don't think
he's ever done openly before and i i
love it he's living
like he knows he's not living much
longer so he's like may as well you know
yeah yeah this could be his own
self-fulfilling prophecy that he just
decides to go on about
but how he dies i mean it's probably
going to be the hands of shigaraki if
not all for one of course but
going off of what i was saying before
about stain i think it's possible that
once all might dies
this might give a reason for staying to
meet up with uzuku because i'm
super curious to see how stain would
react to all might's death
i mean it just ultimately might lead to
like staying potentially just straight
up teaming up with uzugu
i really want those two to have a
conversation uh stain and
all might yeah oh oh we've been waiting
to talk about this so long yeah what the
what the hell what what
and and then we didn't even get to get
the conversation because he just gets
out of prison
and now they're just out in the streets
probably a block from each other
and who knows yeah i mean now that you
mention it stane might not even know
what happened to all might because he's
been in tartarus this whole time i mean
they don't get information there
i mean author one pretty much said it
they don't get told what's happening in
the outside world
so when staying broke out recently he
probably doesn't know that all might
have lost all his powers and is this
old man so it would be really i guess if
they met it would be kind of surreal for
staying to see him like that and also
little does he know of like
the connection between all might and
deku like
the just how deep that goes like yeah
that'd be really interesting to explore
i do really agree that deku and stan
also need to have a conversation moving
on to my last prediction because i had
another one but it was about the sports
festival so we kind of already mentioned
that being cancelled
um so the last one that i had on my list
was the death of a student
and you know it doesn't have to be a
major player it doesn't have to be
backup or something like that
but um just a student dying it feels
like
these guys have been sent to the
battlefield already right we had the
whole war arc
where if we're being realistic a student
could have died very easily in that
whole situation you know
with shigaraki and gigantomaki and all
that um
it's almost kind of lucky that a student
didn't die so i feel like going forward
if we're gonna be you know if it's the
end game you can kill off characters at
this point i i feel
um and i also feel like during the war
arc one too many characters survived
i'm looking at grand touring
specifically um
so i feel like we need to compensate for
that a little bit in the final act but
you know
a student should die just in the heated
battle maybe uh it could be a great
moment i feel like
nah but you're gonna have a lot of marks
in the comments after this question
saying that like well they'll never kill
a student because uh
jump won't allow it blah blah blah it's
like okay
no i feel like worse has happened in
other series trust me yeah like they
definitely would allow it especially if
the series is ending
i feel like it's free range vigilantes
they killed shirakumo you know he was a
student
uh that's valid yeah you can't do that i
mean if you're doing it in a side manga
surely in the main series you could do
it once right like before the end of the
series you can do it one time
oh wait a second that's a good thing to
bring up i mean
we don't want to run the video too long
but just him just you know
coming back true yeah actually during
the prison break we didn't
see him did we i don't it wasn't
explicitly confirmed that
um kurogiri was broken out i mean i
guess he was but it just
wasn't shown yeah we can only assume
that he was you know because
he was there i'm sure they didn't just
leave him there like they showed
him okay okay so he probably is broken
out that doesn't bode well
i remember um i had this debate on
twitter a long time ago and it's about
whether erie could
rewind him potentially and i remember
some people saying like you can't do it
because then he'd just end up dead
because he's technically a uh
technically a corpse you know a nomu i
was of the opposite opinion i was
thinking that no you can turn him back
to normal
because you know we've seen for a fact
he's still in there regardless of what
yeah might think he's in there
yeah if all might said that she could
turn somebody back to a monkey
then she could turn uh kurogiri back to
a you know shirakumo
that was all my predictions though guys
did you have any ones left over
i have i have one about shigaraki and
all for one
so uh i think that the solution for
dealing with all for one's control of
sugar rocky is going to somehow be
involving
taking all for one from shigaraki but
when you do that
as deku you're going to have to deal
with now you have the all for one
vestige
a vestige as we see in chicago investors
can literally take control of a person
yes so that's the worrying thing like if
he's always there you know
however unlikely there's always that
zero point one percent chance that
off one could take over whoever
whoever's consciousness is
he's in that's really interesting though
uh as far as deku having to have that
battle of wills
but i feel like if you do that you free
shigaraki from
uh all for one's control and then what's
he left with he's left with this
ridiculous body that he has and i would
assume
what decay his body by itself he
wouldn't even
to be a threat he didn't he doesn't even
need decay like he's just ridiculous
yeah he's
he's crazy shawn did you have any lost
words
no i i agree with pineapple on that i
never even thought about that but that
would be a
great ending to all for one if he's just
like ganged up on
by the vestiges in the vestige world and
they finally get their ultimate revenge
on him
yeah because he killed him basically
yeah
awesome guys well thank you for helping
on the channel today and uh for anyone
watching who hasn't already subscribed
to these guys then the link is in the
description
they make great content so you
definitely need to check it out thank
you hey
anytime buddy until the next one peace
out